not long after enlisting in the indian
armed forces
khali was disappointed to learn that
women were not allowed to serve in
combat units
this led to establishing a private
security company that would operate
within india's borders
later on she would broaden her reach and
founded the pmc
nighthaven that would operate across the
globe
as part of a joint ewing operation in
somalia between nighthaven and the
norwegian foshwaretz
facial commando kali's life was saved by
an fsk operator
going by the code name ace the days that
followed
sure ace being offered a position within
nighthaven
in 2019 six invited knighthaven to join
team rainbow
to bring their skills and expertise in
assisting in the fight against terrorism
on a global scale one of these operators
was named ace
[Music]
wow
[Music]
there is no chasm too wide no wall too
thick
that will stop me from bringing you home
howard hogland codenamed ace is an
attacking operator in team rainbow
as an only child ace was born in a small
historical village
called leo disori in norway
with a population of just over a
thousand roughly 220 of them were under
the age of 19.
as a consequence of growing up in this
environment he had very little
competition from other children his own
age
he was constantly praised and admired
for everything he did
as the only child of his doting parents
they had a very strong bond with their
son
he was afforded their time their
resources and their unwavering
admiration
with his peers he was considered a bit
of an idol and he was popular and
outgoing
and often engaged in a number of
extracurricular activities
in such a highly praised environment it
is easy to see why he could imagine
himself stepping
straight into such an advanced role as a
pediatric surgeon
after all he was the best at everything
else he set his mind to
however he soon discovered that being
the admired pediatric surgeon he had
always dreamed of
was not quite as straight cut as he
thought and while he scored very high in
his grade point average in high school
it had never occurred to him the time
and effort he would need to undertake
in his chosen profession the requirement
of at least four years of medical school
five years of general surgery and at
least two years of residency
meant his dream was going to take a very
long time and he soon discovered that
memorizing the theory that went along
with this profession wasn't to his
liking
he had to work out how to get the action
the fastest way possible
and becoming a paramedic looked like his
best opportunity
training involved taking part in a
number of specialized emt classes
at university for only one year and also
completing two years of working
alongside an emt mentor on an ambulance
but eventually the job became lackluster
and he craved
more more excitement more admiration
and more notable heroics his desire for
the approval of others
and their unwavering adoration towards
him was starting to wane
he realized he had to step up his game
so he joined the norwegian armed forces
where he completed 10 weeks of basic
training
there he was able to develop even more
skills he enlisted with the norwegian
home guard
a rapid mobilization force whose focus
was on the local defense and civil
support
but it can also detach volunteers for
international operations
it is here that he gained an even larger
following of fans
his dazzling charm and heroical
performances his captivating snapshots
and his incomparable skills in the field
a social media star
was born after completing his service
obligation
he was accepted into the forshvarets
special commando
and took part in a prominent hostage
rescue soon afterwards
this organization is a special
operations unit of the norwegian special
operations forces
established due to an increased risk of
terrorist activity against norwegian
interests including oil platforms in the
north sea
it was at this time with the fsk that he
took part in an important host rescue
situation
a joint operation with the u.n in
somalia
his tendency to over dramatize using
theatrics
and his impulsive style resulted in a
magnificent display
in saving khali's life so unsurprisingly
not long after the successful operation
an offer to join nighthaven was swiftly
made
frontline disaster relief takes a
certain type of person
it often involves outlining the
potential outcomes of the options
available
and then comparing these outcomes to
determine which was the best option
risks can be identified classified and
compared to make the choice between
acceptable
and unacceptable outcomes and although
ace at first glance
might not fit the profile as it can come
across a bit brash
self-interested and arrogant
he seems to have a certain innate drive
and protecting the welfare of others
he's ambitious but he goes to lengths to
make sure that none are harmed by his
actions
he is capable of making those in his
care feel safe and secure
whether he's gingerly making his way to
a trapped avalanche victim
or tending to a broken bone it's his
assertiveness
and self-assurance that allows him to
overcome his emotions in these dangerous
missions
the photo opportunities he gains through
his work provides him with an enticing
portfolio online
he is a personification of the perfect
upstanding citizen
a golden boy and it was only further
reinforced when he was conscripted into
the army
and his subsequent role as a combat
medic
his time with the norwegian armed forces
has honed his rescue skills
as an emt he projects a calm confidence
in even the most stressful situations
to his followers he is the ultimate hero
and he craves the positive publicity and
attention he receives
social media has allowed the small town
boy the opportunity
to highlight as many feats to the world
he always seems to know exactly where to
stand for the perfect shot
whether it's creating a breach for his
teammates or smiling for the camera
but behind the facade there must surely
be a struggle
how can a person always be so switched
on composed and seemingly perfect
his desire to tightly control how he's
perceived by others must undoubtably be
exhausting at times
like any individual no matter the
reputation he has insecurities
it's just that they are no way crippling
to his image
his followers from around the world they
see him as the hero he wishes them to
see
he wears a social mask well he hides his
true feelings
and any self-doubts from the world
because that's his job
as an emt as a member of nighthaven and
as a social media star
to be the perfect soldier
when working with others he's
charismatic friendly and sociable
and he excels in working closely with
his peers
[Music]
his skills certainly live up to the hype
that he's helped create
and although his personality makes him
likable and sociable
he can also be a bit of a dick at times
however he's valued by others around him
at least until the time comes to give an
interview after a successful mission
and then it's all ace ace ace
he speaks very highly of specialist
khali and they both are very fortunate
their paths crossed
while their relationship is certainly
beneficial for both of them
it seems that as long as ace remains
committed to fame and fortune
he'll continue to sing kylie's praises
and remain loyal to her
knighthaven and kylie are his ticket to
a successful online presence
as a social media influencer it's a whom
you know business
and the excitement and drama of his job
certainly ups his profile
what's also clear is that his heart very
much still remains in norway
and with his family the question is
whose approval is he trying to gain his
parents
kelly the world and is there ultimate
approval
even a possibility being a social media
personality is a really lonely thing
influencers are often under emotional
pressure since their life and
performance are always under public
scrutiny
followers expect consistent quality
content and find it easy to turn against
influences when expectations are not met
so before i started this video i thought
ugh this guy such a douchebag
i don't talk about him but after looking
into it a bit further
i started to feel somewhat sympathetic
towards him those struggles may be a lot
less extreme than some of the other
operators
he still has his own things to work
through and figure out
and although i don't consider myself
some sort of influencer i'm
more of a storyteller or maybe a content
creator at best
i understand the need to shield oneself
through an image or persona
and that it can be a pretty lonely place
behind that outer shell
jesus they got deep fast apologies it's
been a busy few weeks for me
i had actually planned to make this some
sort of night haven part 2 video but due
to time constraints and the fact that
i've waffled on for quite a while with
ace alone
i'll instead release the aruni video
separately and that should be out soon
anyway i hope you've enjoyed this video
and i'll catch in the next one
cheers
no